is now breaking news alert good evening
and thank you for joining us tonight at
six o'clock we continue to follow
breaking news this evening
a fire in an apartment complex near
sahara and maryland parkway has caused
the evacuation of many people in that
area
madison kimbrough joins us live on the
scene with the latest
madison sasha the scene has definitely
calmed down since earlier today but as
you can take a look you can see the
extent
of this scene it is quite extensive as
several apartment units are now
destroyed the fire started around three
today and the clark county fire
department and the city of las vegas
fire and rescue were on scene
we still don't know how the fire started
but it brought six fire engines two
trucks
two rescues and two battalion chiefs
residents were asked to immediately
evacuate the area
and since arriving we've seen several
people out in the parking lot and on the
side of the street
we spoke to two residents who are out of
their apartments right now as fire
officials assess the situation
we live at the 48 over there
in the solar east and then my mom saw
that over there and it started smoking
and then we came over here because we
want to see what's happening and then we
all just i'll see all this
i mean it's crazy you know what i'm
saying people got kids and
you know people got to be careful i was
just here maybe like 30 40 minutes ago
and then i went in my
house to play some fort so fortnight and
i came out
and i can't even get get through
a second alarm was requested for
additional backup and at the start there
were 55 personnel on scene
that number has now decreased but still
a lot of activity
as like i said many of these residents
are now out of their apartments
in the parking lot just assessing the
situation this damage
is extensive and it's looking like it
probably ruined about
six to seven different apartment
complexes and units that you see right
here
now we spoke to several residents here
that say this is not the first time a
fire has started on this property
many other times from 2017 to even 2012
and earlier back on
so we're going to look into that later
on in the later shows but we're going to
send it back to you sasha
as more details come through we will
make sure to bring you the latest
reporting live madison kimbrough
8 news now